[Music]
my honor is hanging by a thread that
grows more precarious with every moment
in your presence
i want my sister to be happy
can you make her happy
[Music]
true love is worth it
things are heating up between lord
anthony and kate sharma in season two of
bridgerton but did we mention they're
kinda in a love triangle this is only
the beginning it's just going to get
more exciting convoluted and sexier i
think the season 2 trailer just dropped
and fans get a glimpse into the eldest
bridgerton's journey to find love
this is the season the vi count intends
to find a wife
you honestly just did that i believe i
did
i know that the story is going to be
really exciting as it is in the books
anthony courts edwina sharma first
kate's younger sister only hope they
like me all you have to do this evening
is remember what it is you're looking
for but any suitor wishing to gain an
audience with miss edwina sharma must
first tame her sister
the sister the sister turns out kate who
is played by newcomer simone ashley
she's very protective and not afraid to
speak her mind newton is an excellent
judge of character
see
[Music]
and it's clear the two have undeniable
chemistry which leads us back to the
love triangle can you really not see
anything engaging about it yes i suppose
i can see how he might engage
a person
[Music]
lord antony himself played by jonathan
bailey teased that the vi counts love
story is going to be layered lots and
lots of layers i think it's going to be
quite a complicated um affair as we know
of anthony um i think there's a lot that
he needs to learn um and a lot he can
learn from daphne i'm sure and simon and
speaking of daphne and simon
you must know men are always interested
in a woman when they believe another
duke
to be interested as well you presume
lady whisperer i presume sure they must
be precisely what we are me unavailable
you
desirable
we sadly won't see reggae john page this
time around after he got hearts racing
as the duke of hastings in season one
but we will see his wife she's back to
help her big brother find love
anthony will need all the help he can
get he seeks a wife only to fulfill his
duty and does not believe in the true
love you deserve it is a poor player who
plays the game and a wise one who plays
their opponent are you in a losing mood
my mood shall remain unchanged
daphne and anthony have such a good
relationship
and he involved himself so much in her
in the duke that's now daphne's trying
to be like i'm gonna be involved in what
you're doing i'm gonna figure out you
know and there's a lot going on it's
extremely dramatic as for nicola
coughlin's character major spoiler alert
if you haven't seen season one yet she's
the town gossip lady whistle down aka
penelope featherington so you must know
dear reader that decision shall be left
entirely up to me
yours truly
lady whistled down
oh and she's still up to her old antics
and it seems this season someone is
trying to take her down lady dan's words
carry far too much import we must entrap
the scribbler genius idea man yes that
is why i thought of it you definitely
see more sides to her i think you know
we find out at the end of season one
that
that is there but we don't get to
explore it but like the world cracks
open i feel like the bridge of tomorrow
just has grown and you're going to see a
lot more size to her she is
she's a sassy chick
[Music]
you